Iran is sending a new warning to the US
as tensions between the two nations
continue to rise iran's Foreign Minister
is promising to firmly confront any
aggression or threat by the US including
any violation against its borders the
warning follows president Trump's
last-minute decision to abort a military
strike against Iran in retaliation for
Iran's downing of an unmanned US
military drone we get more now from
Paula Reid at the White House Paula what
can you tell us Michelle for now another
military strike does not appear imminent
but as tensions continue to escalate
between Tehran and Washington the Trump
administration is considering other
possibilities including another round of
sanctions against Iran as soon as next
week
president Trump tweeted Friday that the
u.s. military had been cocked and loaded
for a strike against Iran Thursday but
he says he called it off at the last
minute when he was told the number of
Iranian casualties that were expected in
an interview with NBC News the president
said that he had not given a final
go-ahead
when Pentagon officials spoke to him
just before the strikes were scheduled
to launch I said how many people are
going to be killed sir I'd like to get
back to you on that great people these
generals they said came back said sir
approximately 150 the plan was to launch
multiple strikes at three of Iran's air
defense systems which would have been
fully manned around-the-clock
and I thought about it for a second I
said you know what they shut down an
unmanned drone plane whatever you want
to call it and here we are sitting with
150 dead people that would have taken
place probably within a half an hour
after I said go ahead and I didn't like
it I didn't think it was I didn't think
it was proportionate that plane the
Iranian shot down was a 110 million
dollar Global Hawk drone
it was unclear why the president was
receiving information about potential
casualties so late in the process on
Capitol Hill the president's restraint
drew praise from House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi the strength of that amount of
collateral damage would be very
provocative and I'm glad the president
did not take that but also exposed
divides within the Republican Party
about an appropriate response we simply
can't allow America's adversary to think
that they can shoot down a US military
drone with impunity the failure to
respond to this kind of direct
provocation that we've seen now from the
Iranians in particular over the last
several weeks could could in fact be a
very serious mistake President Trump
says he is not looking for a war and he
warns that any conflict between the u.s.
and Iran would be quote obliteration
you've never seen before but he did say
that he is open to talking to Iran
without preconditions
Jeff hey Paula thank you very much